So, let's see if we understood
the relationship between refreshes and
reads.
Suppose we have a memory array that
has 4,096 rows and 2,048 columns and
suppose that the refresh period for
this array is 500 micro-second.
Every cell needs to be refreshed within
this time, otherwise it will lose data.
Now suppose that the timing for
reads for this memory is as follows.
It takes us four nanoseconds
to select a row.
Once we activate the row,
ten nanoseconds are needed for
the sense amplifier to get
the bit values from that row.
Two nanoseconds are needed to put
that data in the row buffer and
four nanoseconds are needed for
the column decoder
to actually figure out which bit
from the row buffer we need.
While this is happening, we are writing
the data back from the sense
amplifier to the memory row, and
it takes us 11 nanoseconds to do that.
So this part overlaps with these two.
So the question for
you is how many data, or
nonrefresh reads per second
can this memory support?
Put your answer here.